It's the same as the day of the day You suddenly stood up
and said Tonight, I'm going to see you go I'm going to go
What are you going to do?
And everyone knows you and I laughed The ungodly way The
ungodly way The way Like a pucker like you're shabby Like a
kid with a cold And I'm glad you I'm sure you're going to be
I'm going to be able to Not be I'm going to be From the
beginning of the night, The night sky is The stars are full
of the stars It's from the beginning To the world On the
moon, I'm the only one To get away Don't be afraid Come
here, come here, come here, come here, come here, Come here,
come here, come here, You are your hands, your
nuts I've yet to find the only female, But where is the
hippo-boss-sah-ma?
This is a little bit lonely.
It's a fun-giant one, one of you.
I can't say anything, I'm gonna say something, I'll tell you
about you.
I knew it was.
I knew it was always.
I don't know.
It's not.
Don't cry.
I just want to hear.
Oh.
I'm a strong girl.
I'm a big and I don't know.
I was like, but But the the that's all I love that's all,
that's all, that's all,
Go to the bottom, go to the heart.
The heart is loud.
The world is so sad.
The truth is sad.
I didn't want to say, I didn't want to say, I can't do it
again.
I'm not going to be able to go back on that summer day.
The shining stars are still there, but I can't remember it.
The smiling face, the angry face, the angry face.
I loved it.
It's a bit weird, but I know it's not that you know that you
don't know it's my only my own secret to the night over the
night over my old memories you give me a Oh, you'll be able
to do it with an inaudient voice.